yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing fm+ easily do 197 so certainly
Newark on Roger this looks pretty fresh
never played them so it's going for this
this line 6 are you serious okay so
where do you go with this to inspector
h5 okay one thing I have to take into
account is that if you take on the fifth
form yeah really take on the phone you
cancel long interesting question if I
should just go Queen 84 or not huh also
do you take 125 or not better not easy
to say please f4 it's not a good square
LSG five always so that that won't work
I can also try c5 in this position that
is absolutely ready to play me five man
that would be most likely questionable
okay I'm taking this is a bit lame
admittedly
you
I wonder a piece space the tech is
probably difficult to pull off nitin civ
5 would be good like bishop out c1965
but is always going to harass my piece
down the bishop here not even a 3 B 4 9
8 45 is this it's not very very speedy
detect but we'll see what he is doing ok
yeah well this is this is excellent if
you takes it and not taking fkg g4 i
have 9 h form it's nothing special let's
put that on the behalf
XD form and I wonder if I actually take
first or not or just night h4
immediately then also comes into
consideration quite getting well and so
Queen 84 threatening threatening Queen
to be five which is not ignored and what
isn't clearly five good okay it black
survive this set would be cool I mean
Quincy eight hard to believe so I can
take on b6 noun 1 Bishop see 767 that's
not quite doing it take here take the
six it takes the night would be money
doesn't look like you should be able to
withstand that still wonder if I have
something something more powerful here
doesn't look like a winner b6
immediately but if i move the night he
might just play Queen B 7 so let's do it
that move I didn't even consider okay
which doesn't mean it is bad I just say
I don't consider it and consider it we
should be eight Wow everything's hanging
him time warning let's just keep the
night that c4 would be a cool player and
actually have no time him so I have to
be somewhat speeding okay
ok now this position is of course
totally winning but with this time not
freezing rupee 695 night exercise maybe
isn't completely clear ok
King bee 795 is a deadly pen I think
okay it's got absolutely no move let's
write the screens is five and just trade
trade everything yes exactly I mean it's
just about he winning on time or I mean
just why this game is over long longer
move over for a while already but it's
yet o'clock it's the free and clock okay
i am ok we know the deal ok ok ok nine
can become promote please you can get it
was extremely unnecessary against this
it's ok this is one of those games where
I think I rather not say too much so
can't this is a this into the view and
chances Queen icicle it's kind of a
pointer shanks analyze this check check
completely completely busted just
between f5 he can still cannot take
i-395 a stronger I mean this is of
course also objectively winning but 2026
not that bad 93 is strong yeah that's
really a strong move but tell me I was
just trying to play as quickly as
possible and TM yeah I just splendid the
poor matt horn and so next opening year
service yeah let's say risky to be
friendly around here yeah I don't see I
don't see how black is justifying this
I'm a bit surprised that the engine is
just giving a slight advantage maybe you
need more please more time or so it
really looks terrible at least here
metrics channel so yeah is this may be a
maybe I should play it without
sacrificing stuff that's possible or
allowing him to take him he never played
the critical lines obviously I mean
taking taking on a three wasn't clear I
mean absolutely not but he was
completely content with going to work
totally lost position and then I screwed
it up now this is even here anymore I
mean there are so many possibilities
night h4 it seems a stronger not to d2
maybe a looking at those squares could
be he doesn't have h4m and I'm not
materially down in this position I mean
yes terrible structure now the cleanest
was probably a little bit later chance
to play this can't we Mia to check
Queenie seventh to break rina five so
this was pretty strong we cannot move
the night and he's a mean what do you
play in this position you know you can
barely move that I just as opposed to
too slow in this whole game to punish
the circus stuff okay thanks for
watching